right a polynomial to express the total
value of P $20 bills P $20 bills Q $10
bills and our $5 bills so what's the
value of P $20 bills well if I have P
$20 bills the value of each of those
dollar bills is going to be $20 so the
value of all P of them is going to be 20
P 20 P right if I have one dollar bill
one $20 bill it's $20 if I have three
$20 bills if P is three it's going to be
$60 actually let me do that in the same
colors i underlined it I underlined it
in yellow so let me do the P $20 bills
so 20 P is the P $20 bills then you have
your Q $10 bills so plus so what's the
value of those well it's going to be 10
Q if I have one ten dollar bills for $10
if I have ten $10 bills if Q is 10 is
going to be worth 10 times 10 $100 and
then finally you have your are five
dollar bills which are going to be worth
five R dollars one five dollar bill
worth five dollars to five dollar bills
worth ten dollars and we're done we've
expressed it as a polynomial polynomial
just means that we have multiple terms
here and this is three terms we could
even call it a trinomial polynomial is a
more general term for more than one term